Mi-na! Let's have a hangover brunch.
I thought I had sobered up, but now I feel sick.
Man! I kept drinking and drinking last night...
...and I couldn't resist people from filling my glass.
One of my colleagues told me that it's rude to say no...
...when a person in a higher position offers you a drink.
What can I say?
I'm in an entry level position and almost all of them there are in a higher position.
Well, I'd say drinking is fun and I enjoy spending time with people from work,...
...but last night was just too much.
I can totally picture you sitting there with an awkward smile on your face.
Poor Alex.
Believe it or not, you can see how Korean people love drinking alcohol.
In fact, all of the people that I know drink like fish.
Well, there's one significant difference between when you have a drink with your normal friends...
...and occasions when you have a drink with somebody like your boss.
When your boss offers you a glass of soju, you can't just take a sip,...
...but you must empty the glass.
Then you should return the empty glass to him to have it filled once again with more soju.
Eww, that doesn't sound very hygienic,...
...but the sharing is what bonds people together I guess,...
...but recent scientific research has revealed...
...that this could lead to the spreading of germs and even viruses!